so I think that the question how mind
fits into nature or how mind relates to
meta in the way that we are used to
asking it right now is completely
opposed on on many different fronts so
let me begin you know for saying
something about you know the book tides
why the world does not exist what I'm
denying is the metaphysical principle of
the unity of reality so for one thing I
believe it's philosophically misguided
to believe that there's one big entity
or domain the world and that we have to
fit everything into that domain which
would be defined for instance as the
absolute totality of everything which
exists and then you could start debating
about you know what really exists this
mind really existed this matter really
exists etc if that's the way of
approaching the topic then you're ready
misguided because you make way too many
metaphysical assumptions that I think
are ultimately untenable so first of all
I think we have to overcome metaphysics
and therefore also questions such as you
know should we be dualist that is should
we believe that there two kinds of
substances should we be monist
that is believe that there's just one
substance should we be pluralist that is
belief that there are whatever many
substances okay so I think the early
modern debates that are still with us
and that has posed the problem of
consciousness the way that we are still
discussing it I think those debates are
as misguided as early modern physics so
all of this is misguided we need a new
framework in order to ask the question
nevertheless there are versions of the
question that are with us that are
tenable but you have to rephrase the
premises of the debate or so I believe
so let's look for instance at the
notions like minds and consciousness and
self consciousness etc what's remarkable
if you come from a different you know
like non-english speaking communities
such as a german-speaking community is
how surprising it is you know like we
have no German word for what in English
is called mind you cannot translate mind
into English as much as you cannot
translate the German word Geist into
English okay they are not exact cinnamon
so I have a hard time even understanding
what people mean when they ask you know
mind that matter you know mind for me is
like shhhhh mind you know so you have to
give me you have to give it meaning and
when I look at you know the meaning that
people are trying to give it you know
then philosophers at least will tell you
something like you know if you want to
know what mine is
you gotta find the mark of the mental
what's the mark of the mental well the
mark of the mental is what makes
something mental instead of non mental
well that's of course not very helpful
because mental is just let in for mine
so that doesn't really get us anywhere
so what they then say and that is still
the most hopeful way of even making
sense of the question I think if they
say something like yeah forget about
mine let's talk about consciousness and
then things get really tricky because I
think that consciousness might also mean
all sorts of things some things that we
call consciousness I think of course
biological phenomena such as being awake
you know the fact that I'm awake right
now and not you know so drunk that I
can't even engage in a debate well those
sacks I'm not on LSD I'm for all I know
you know like those facts are biological
obviously so there's no I don't think
there's a meta problem there first of
all we can explain them etc so I don't
believe that there's what people have
called the heart problem I don't think
that there you know you can look at my
brain and then it looks stupid and just
pink and but from within you know I'm
awake so how do days they relate to each
other well here's how they relate to
each other you know if your brain is a
certain state in a certain state then
you are awake so that depth that's I
think it's not a problem but there are
problems with consciousness such as you
know like how can I ever be in a truth
ed state I think that's an interesting
question so how can brains have access
to truth ed States even though brains
you know do not seem particularly suited
to you know due to their evolutionary
origin etc - grasping you know as it
were pure truth such as two plus two
equals four etc so how is it possible
that brains you know realize states that
make it possible for us to significantly
go beyond anything that takes place
within our heads so you know to throw
out another credo you know the external
credo but a little bit more generalized
I think that you know parts of
consciousness just ain't in the head so
if you're looking for consciousness you
know within your skull then you will
find some elements of what we
legitimately call consciousness and they
are not mysterious but you will also
find you know other features that we
ascribe to consciousness such as you
know those features that put us in
contact with something outside our
skulls
for me the real interesting question is
how is it possible for you know
organisms to grasp propositions I think
that's an interesting question
that comes with all sorts of riddles but
the riddles are quite different from
those that you know the metaphysical
framework is allowed to post within
which we are currently operating I think
that framework is profoundly confused